welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the godzilla vs kong trailer
gives me everything i want from a kaiju
movie a bunch of
years and come on over two titans
jousting like my brother and me on pool
wrapped with foam noodles
never knock him in the water it's what
he wants after i broke down 2019's
godzilla king of the monsters
i'm back baby you ready to break down
all the details you might have
overlooked in this trailer
due to all the rainy debris crazy
research walls what kong's axe is made
out of
why they're fighting and who the real
monster is
and no for once it's not humans well it
kinda is it's always us
spoiler warning in case i reveal too
much and here we go yeah come on so the
trailer opens with the destruction of a
city looks like seoul
and right away above the collapsing
buildings is a titan that you might
think is godzilla but
its metallic exterior actually looks
more like
mechagodzilla so what is going on here
let's
back up godzilla vs kong has been in the
works since the post-credits scene of
2017's kong skull
island with cave paintings showing an
ancient battle between these two titans
2019's godzilla king of the monsters
showed godzilla battling the
three-headed king ghidorah awoken from
antarctic ice by the eco-terrorist
organization apex
godzilla defeated ghidorah in boston
with the help of
mothra and this whale-derived sonar tech
called
orca all to help godzilla alpha the
various other titans from the tunnels of
the hollow earth including rodan
steering all these kaiju away from
populated areas and living overall
peacefully with humanity kong was
mentioned in this movie but not seen
then this movie's post-credit scene
showed apex head alan jonah charles
dance recovering one severed head of
ghidorah for some evil scheme and now
that plan appears to be to fuse the
ghidorah brain
with the skeletal remains found in the
2014 godzilla to construct
mecca godzilla which apex can control
and thus likely control all the other
titans on earth mechagodzilla might be
being used by apex to frame godzilla for
this destruction
similar to the plot of 1974's godzilla
vs mechagodzilla some believe the
godzilla we see
in this trailer footage is actually
mechagodzilla in disguise
and that after kong rips open this titan
the mecha skeleton will be revealed i'm
not so sure about that i think a lot of
the godzilla we see in this trailer is
the actual godzilla and then what starts
as a duel between
kong and godzilla could end up as a kind
of team up with the two of them against
mechagodzilla but before we get to that
kong is now being shipped in to deal
with this rogue kaiju
he has since grown a lot since its 2017
film apparently due to radiation in
those hollow earth tunnels
and you see here his big hand is getting
soaked in water while he sleeps yeah
that's totally gonna make him piss
himself next the studio logos up here
alongside those cave paintings with this
new techno glow spreading across
as if to suggest this toxic
technological influence of mechagodzilla
you can even see the neon outline of
its head ahead of godzilla as the
legendary logo fades to black then we
meet
gia played by kaylee hoddle a death
actress actually coming from a four
generation deaf family
gia is a girl on skull island with a
connection to kong
she's got these tattoos maybe from a
tribe who worshipped and cohabitated
with kong
alexander skarsgard plays geologist
nathan lind who oversees kong's
transport from skull island rebecca hall
plays eileen andrews she is kind of
caretaker
suggesting gia might be the last of that
tribe and the only human left who can
communicate
with this titan now here we get a great
example of what has always been my
favorite element of these recent films
the sense of scale
the way these titans interact with the
smaller buildings tiny vehicles and
humans
to evoke that sense of awe and wonder
and how big they are
this finger two-finger connection does
kind of evoke michelangelo's creation of
adam
now with the double irony of adam as
this young girl
and god as an ancient giant ape as
mankind's protector kog's advantage in
this movie is his capacity to use a tool
his axe recalling the technological
themes of kubrick's 2001 a space odyssey
with the primordial apes taking giant
leaps in evolution
with a similarly primitive weapon but
one that meant a great
deal i'll get to the deeper significance
of this axe and yeah yeah enough of the
collegiate [ __ ] let's get to that come
on yes
all right so godzilla interrupts kong's
transit making me think kong is being
brought in to contain the threat that
will end up being mechagodzilla but that
the real godzilla
as an ancient rival to kong will
intercept him mid
ocean kind of like the [ __ ] are you
doing off skull island now for a brief
moment the music is actually
really great in this trailer it's a nod
to those terrifying choir vocals
from that halo jump teaser from the 2014
godzilla
as kong looks down the water below you
can see these green canisters on his
collar
i assume this is a kind of knockout gas
to subdue him in case he gets out of
control
some are thinking the fluid might be
derived from the soma berries from
1962's king kong vs godzilla where the
juice of this berry was a pharmaceutical
target
and was used to satisfy kong and then
when kong roars down at the waves i love
how his breath comes out as a blast of
vapor
may not be atomic breath but i would
imagine this would rupture your eardrums
if you were too close
scale and point of view are everything
here like when godzilla slams his claw
on the deck an
energy surge rips through then his other
claw crushes a jet as he
bites through a fireball and then almost
be from the point of view of a person on
the deck
caught in the middle between these two
giants because as we tilt up
drops of water spray down on the lens as
if all that ocean water is dripping down
on
us more great detail in the wide shot
the carrier is a kind of
seesaw kong's end is way down
deeper but then it shifts as he takes a
swing a godzilla now this doesn't mean
kong is heavier necessarily because kong
was not on this carry to begin with
godzilla knocked him from that red barge
so kong probably leapt over to this one
moments before causing it to teeter down
more than it would then
kong knocks godzilla off the boat but
like my amphibious brother in the water
is where godzilla is deadliest
as death charges drop down godzilla
charges up himself to emit a blast of
atomic breath and i love how it releases
the shock wave that washes away those
fish swimming in the corner of the
screen it didn't stand a chance ooh but
before i continue a quick word about the
really big news from our merch store the
epic hero shop
we had a lot of fun with our first shirt
in the latest obsession line with our
mandalorian inspired this is the way
shirt the limited run of that shirt
sold out and that design is now locked
up in the blue dungeon for all of
eternity but we have two
new wanda vision inspired designs that
we are super excited about these shirts
are unlike
anything we've done before and really
unlike any shirt i've ever seen
i mean it these shirts are the next
level bonkers cool just like the disney
plus series inspiring them
also really quick we wanted to let you
know yes our merch is always available
at new rockstarsmerch.com but that's in
partnership
with our epic hero shop and we've
actually got
very cool news from epic hero shop
itself that you're gonna want to listen
to
those people that already clicked ahead
you're gonna regret missing this well
for everyone who stayed i want you to
know that epic hero shop
just launched a new mysterious maybe
nerdy maybe
funny maybe who knows youtube channel
and is celebrating that with some
giveaways
of what oh how about just a little thing
called a
sony playstation 5 disc edition
because we know we're all going to try
out our scratched up rayman discs and
that beast
and see what happens i'm pretty sure
it's rayman reaching out and slapping
you with this creepy dismembered hand
but
back to that giveaway as epic hero shop
launches this new channel called
epic hero labs they'll be doing multiple
giveaways
of not one not two but eventually 10
ps5s to honor the road to 100 000
subscribers
and it starts right now you can go to
epic heroshop.com
giveaway or click the link in the
description to enter and you'll see
all the details there but basically
following the various epic hero accounts
gives you
entries it's that simple again full
details at the link in the description
epic heroshop.com giveaway and we will
be publicly announcing the first
giveaway winner after the epic hero labs
youtube channel hits 10 000 subscribers
so if you are over 18
and in the us or canada go get to
entering i'll be here waiting okay
another important shot here
shanuri as ran serizawa son of ken
watanabe's character ashiro let him
fight
sirizawa but look at the screen behind
him battery i think that's the word
there
system's maximum charge and then an
outline of a technological kaiju
i think again we are looking at the
control room for mechagodzilla
and ran might be working for apex in the
operation to try to control him
rebelling from his papa mark russell is
in this camp now based on some other
footage it looks like a monarch
operation
and on the left the tv screen reads
godzilla makes landfall in pensacola
florida as a florida boy i can tell you
pensacola is more of a resort retirement
town not a metropolis like seoul
except there is a key u.s naval base
there this tells us that this must have
been a strategic attack then we get my
favorite thing to always show up in any
movie or tv show a psycho research wall
i assume this one is being kept by
madison and her new friend josh played
by
julian dennison ah come on guys no red
yarn let's break down what we can make
out here
first there's a bunch of confused
newspaper headlines about godzilla
attacks with monarchs stumped as to why
godzilla would now turn on humanity
that's because he's got an evil robot
version of himself doing
it then across the map various post-its
showing godzilla attacks and sightings
most of which seem localized around apex
facilities
other notes suggest a connection between
godzilla and apex
note on the far left speculates godzilla
attacks tend to occur at apex facilities
or government buildings or water
facilities or i think that's pure and
mall
so either these apex attacks are the
real godzilla attacking apex trying to
prevent them from
building mechagodzilla or apex could be
sending mechagodzilla to attack their
own abandoned facilities to cover up
their schemes
and give them some plausible deniability
another note wonders if monarch and apex
are collaborating
possible i don't know if monarch would
want to work with apex unless there was
some kind of corruption at the top but
then at the bottom of this board euan
vetoes godzilla suggesting godzilla
might have been part of the united
nations or a kind of security force that
they tried to work with but that's been
vetoed and then antarctica a no-go for
tourists suggesting people might have
been trying to visit that research
station where gedora attacked in the
last movie so madison and josh are
trying to uncover this conspiracy riding
around in a storm tracking van hooked up
with various seismic scanners and they
meet brian tyree henry as bernie hayes
another conspiracy theorist type person
though in this fictional world hollow
earth has been more or less confirmed so
i don't think the conspiracies are
really theories anymore so then kong
appears in this cave with these drones
hovering around him i'm assuming this is
another hollow earth tunnel
these things are being used by monarch
or by apex to follow the titan down
there
there's this red handprint mark maybe
marking the place where kong retrieves
his
axe now this axe later we see the blade
of the axe deflecting godzilla's atomic
breath
pretty impressive what is this thing
made out of well if you look closely
at it it looks like a spiky plate that
had been yanked out of godzilla's back
or tail
it's part of godzilla and you can tell
by the shape of the blade which bears
those distinctive
curved hooks from when godzilla's plates
were redesigned for the 2019 film from
the 2014 film to look more like the
original 1954 gojira design meanwhile
the handle of this
axe was a tree grown by the natives of
skull island the people who worshipped
him
and wanted him to be their protector
even godzilla himself seems to know this
blade came from him that close-up
showing that giant axe
godzilla is staring directly at it like
god damn it that's mine and then as
irene talks about the mythologized war
among the titans we see this flashback
of kong swinging one kaiju into another
this is the warbat aka nozuki i love
the spray of the yellow blood that
gushes out upon impact in the background
the terrain is looking kind of trippy
it's kind of floating above them it
looks like there's sky
in between the ground nearby is purple
so yeah we are looking at some ancient
surreal hollow earth maybe where gravity
doesn't totally make sense
and then after some more brutal battle
shots we end on this amazing collision
between the titans
i love how the atomic breath reflects
off each skyscraper surface as it beams
toward kong
lighting up kong's head so that we get
to see each individual stranded drool
between his teeth now at first kong
appears to be blocking the blast but as
he comes down on godzilla that radiation
appears to be
charging up the blade as if godzilla's
plate is sucking in that blast
super charging it up so that he can
bring it down with more explosive impact
unlike thor when he was in the scenario
kong smartly goes for the head now the
only thing missing from this awesome
trailer is mothra who did
die at the end of the last film though
the credit sequence mentioned a
mysterious giant egg was found
indicating that mothra might make a
surprise entrance in this one we'll find
out when godzilla vs kong premiere on
hbo max this march
26th oh by the way this hi i'm eric ross
shirt is available for purchase at a
merch store near rockstarsmerch.com
along with a ton of great nerdy designs
all of which support this channel
directly
follow me on instagram ideavos follow
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars on
youtube for more breakdowns of
everything you love thank you for
watching bye
[Music]
you